we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman president donald trump has
been impeached again making him the only
president in history to be impeached two
times and in fact
this has been a presidency rife with
firsts
but they're all pretty bad and we're
going to talk about that in a subsequent
segment but yes donald trump becoming
the first president to be impeached
twice the house this time voting on just
a single charge
citing trump's role ins in inciting that
mob that violently went to the capitol
on january 6th and donald trump now will
face a senate trial that could
disqualify him from future office
although that senate trial by every
indication isn't going to happen until
joe biden assumes the presidency
ten republicans joined
democrats in the house of
representatives
in voting yesterday for the impeachment
of donald trump this was now a capital
much more
militarized much more fortified by law
enforcement and military
as a result of what took place on
january 6 let's go to the moment that it
happened nancy pelosi announcing the
results for the second time during
donald trump's presidency that indeed
the president has been impeached
on this vote the eyes are 232
the nays are 197
the resolution is adopted without
objection the motion to reconsider is
laid upon the table
congratulations
so going forward when we say
the trump impeachment
we are going to need to clarify which of
the two trump impeachments we're
referring to and notably different this
time versus the house vote about a year
ago a little more than a year ago in
impeaching donald trump the first time
ten republicans joining the democrats uh
congressman
catco liz cheney kinzinger upton
herrera butler newhouse mayer gonzalez
rice and valedao
joining the democratic party i don't
think that these republicans are
particularly valiant or brave although
we will talk on the bonus show today
about how liz cheney
is facing calls to resign because she
voted for the impeachment of donald
trump can you imagine
resign
because you
did the thing
that is your responsibility and duty to
do as a member of the house of
representatives very backwards very
backwards calls for resignation we are
hearing uh from republicans and this is
going to be yet another stain on donald
trump's legacy only one week before
leaving office to the day
and um we are i mean listen this this is
we talk we've talked a lot over the last
four years
as we've fallen further and further down
in terms of global respectability and as
the shame has grown and the humiliation
has grown we've talked about what will
it take to get back to where we were and
for many of us where we were wasn't that
great i mean okay
diplomatically the united states was
more respected around the world under
barack obama and previous presidencies
but we still were falling behind in
dealing with climate we still weren't
getting health care to everybody uh even
as one of the richest countries in the
world we still had hunger we still had
unemployment you know we we were far
better off than we are now
far more respected but we still had
serious problems to solve
and um we cannot it is unreasonable to
expect
that after this level of global shame
and domestic shame just because the
trumpets don't feel ashamed doesn't mean
it's not significant shame
it took four years for this to culminate
in donald trump's second impeachment and
this riotous mob that he incited it's
going to take more than six months to
make significant headway in in getting
out of it and hopefully our historical
allies uh will will forgive us that's
really the question and there is going
to be a lot of work digging out from
this um even uh many republicans in
house speeches yesterday in the
anticipation of this vote
including representative kevin mccarthy
conceding that yes donald trump was to
blame for what happened at the capitol
last week
but many continuing to insist that
despite that it is not
impeachable so
we are all of course disappointed that
there are unlikely to be greater
consequences for donald trump
if things go incredibly well and the
senate votes to convict when they likely
um in
february march april we don't know
convene for the uh impeachment trial of
trump uh if they were to convict it is
uh a possibility that trump will face
the consequence of not being able to run
again
but we all wish there had been more
consequences and i i think maybe the
biggest takeaway is
were it not for you getting out and
voting in 2018 to take that majority
away in the house of representatives
from republicans were it not for you
voting in 2020
to remove donald trump and to give
democrats a senate majority we wouldn't
even be seeing a lot of what we've seen
the first impeachment wouldn't have
happened were it not for the 2018 vote
the second impeachment i mean
we'd be dealing with a different
situation let's put it that way
were it not for taking the white house
and the senate uh in in november and in
the runoff elections in georgia in
january so there are successes here uh
but we all wish that there had been more
consequences and earlier on for what has
been arguably the most atrocious
presidency in modern political history
donald trump did deliver what i believe
we can safely call his final at address
as president of the united states
yesterday it's basically an
unrecognizable person it it this is not
a trump we have ever seen before uh it's
not like trump uh has been
this person we saw yesterday for the
last four years but was pretending to be
somebody else i believe that the trump
we saw yesterday is a fake trump it is a
desperate trump and trump's speech
yesterday is a desperate plea for mercy
trump is isolated furious abandoned by
many republicans banned from a number of
social media accounts and he sat in the
oval office yesterday
and recorded what he hopes is a speech
that will save him that will take the
pressure off in terms of a possible
impeachment conviction in the senate he
is attempting to dial down the
possibility of future investigations
into his endless wrongdoing let's take a
look at it my fellow americans
i want to speak to you tonight
about the troubling events of the past
week
as i have said the incursion of the u.s
capitol
struck at the very heart of our republic
it angered and appalled millions of
americans
across the political spectrum
i want to be very clear
i unequivocally condemned the violence
that we saw last week
violence and vandalism have absolutely
no place in our country and no place in
our movement
making america great again has always
been about defending the rule of law so
a unifying and empathetic trump right
give me a break guys no one who has been
paying attention for the last really now
five plus years
is falling for this this is trump having
a speech on a prompter shoved in front
of him and being told
this is what you need to say to maybe
save yourself from some of what is
unlike what is likely to be coming and
of course trump now the unifier around
the riots he caused through his two
months of election lies and a speech
saying let's go to the capitol right now
now of course the maga movement has
never been about defending the rule of
law they say that but even before being
uh a president trump would tell his
supporters
that if they are rough with protesters
at his rallies and they get arrested and
charged he'll pay their legal fees now
as we'll find out on the bonus show
today
trump doesn't pay anybody's legal fees
he's not even paying his own but we'll
get to that later let's get to more of
yesterday's bizarre statement from trump
mob violence goes against everything i
believe in
and everything our movement stands for
no true supporter of mind could ever
endorse political violence
no true supporter of mine could ever
disrespect law enforcement
or our great american flag
no true supporter of mine could ever
threaten or harass their fellow
americans
if you do any of these things
you are not supporting our movement you
are attacking it and you are attacking
our country
we cannot tolerate it
tragically over the course of the past
year
made so difficult because of covet 19.
trump caused the mob violence
his supporters led a mob
it's sort of a no true scotsman
situation if anyone rioted then by
definition they couldn't have been my
supporters well sir
they had trump hats
and trump shirts
and trump flags when they broke in and
when they gave interviews they said they
were for trump and when they posted to
social media they said they were for
trump yeah but they weren't true
supporters of mine
indefeasible right it's a closed loop
you can't uh you can't break it as we
talked about last week trump also by the
way mentioned covet 19 there
now trump of course has disastrously
mishandled the virus so everything about
this speech is just fantasy world looney
tunes here's another uniting message
from this new trump whether you are on
the right
or on the left
a democrat
or a republican
there is never a justification for
violence
no excuses
no exceptions
america is a nation of laws
those who engaged in the attacks last
week
will be brought to justice
now i am asking everyone who has ever
believed in our agenda
to be thinking of ways to ease tensions
calm tempers and help to promote peace
in our country now some people might
hear trump say everyone will be brought
to justice and they'll react by saying
wow trump's doing the right thing he's
being tough on the rioters that really
takes takes some strength
trump never cared about the rioters
here's what people have to understand
when they were rioting trump was pleased
initially we know he was liking it and
he liked how it delayed the electoral
vote count he never cared about the
rioters as people he never cared about
the rioters as his voters or supporters
it just was useful to his political
goals then trump noticed that the
writers looked low class that's these
are the reports we got multiple reports
about that trump still didn't care about
them as people he just cared about how
they made him look and low-class rioters
made trump look bad remember trump has
spent his entire life trying to stay
away from people like most of his
supporters at his golf clubs and at his
high-rise apartments and then the
rioters now were getting arrested
and it led to trump's impeachment so
trump denounces them and says they're
not my true supporters and they're going
to be persecuted uh prosecuted to the
fullest extent of the law he's not
abandoning anyone in so far as he was
never actually with them they were
always merely political tools and now
he's using this to try to get points for
lowering the temperature but it's much
too late to matter let's watch a little
bit more donald trump saying don't do
any more riots please
there has been reporting that additional
demonstrations are being planned in the
coming days
both here in washington
and across
the country
i have been briefed by the u.s
secret service
on the potential threats
every american deserves to have their
voice heard
in a respectful and peaceful way
that is your first amendment right
but i cannot emphasize that there must
be no violence
no law breaking and no vandalism of any
kind
everyone must follow our laws and obey
the instructions of law enforcement
i have directed federal agencies to use
all necessary resources
to maintain order
in washington dc we are bringing in
thousands of national guard members
to secure the city and ensure that a
transition can occur safely and without
incident so there it is trump sending a
message no more riots
now trump can't get out of this without
doing some of his typical routines so
here trump goes after social media
platforms for banning him as assaults on
free speech i also want to say a few
words about the unprecedented assault
on free speech
we have seen in recent days
these are tense and difficult times
the efforts to censor cancel and
blacklist
our fellow citizens are wrong
and they are dangerous
what is needed now is for us to listen
to one another
not to silence one another
all of us can choose
by our actions
to rise above the rancor
and find common ground and shared
purpose
we must focus on advancing the interests
of the whole nation
delivering the miracle vaccines
defeating the pandemic
rebuilding the economy
protecting our national security
and upholding the rule of law now of
course the social media stuff is not a
free speech issue i'm not going to get
into into that again we've gone over
that ad nauseam uh and of course
this donald trump
we've never seen this trump because he
doesn't exist this isn't real trump the
real guy
is the guy he has plainly been in public
which matches the guy he's plainly been
in private that's the real trump the
five-minute trump we saw yesterday is
just a pathetic desperate attempt to
save himself and get some mercy so that
republicans when the impeachment trial
starts can say listen trump lowered the
temperature he dialed it down we're not
going to vote to convict that's the goal
and one more thing
if this would have been trump all along
it would have been fake but he would
have gotten re-elected if with the virus
trump had done that and said this is a
tough time let's listen to the doctors
no mass anti-mass protest just listen to
the doctors
way fewer people would have died and
trump would have sailed to re-election
there would have been no riot and trump
would be getting another four years too
little too late from fake trump
let me know your reaction i'm on twitter
at deepak the david pakman show at
davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
our program is mostly made possible by
folks like you who grab a membership at
jointpakman.com
you can use the coupon code if you so
please to get a big discount that coupon
code is better21 all one word all
lowercase a few interesting posts on the
david pakman show subreddit i i invite
you to join us there um respectful
political discussion with just 27 000 of
our closest friends in the audience you
can go to davidpakman.com
reddit
a very interesting post about what if
what happened on january 6th had
happened when barack obama had been
president and what if it was 2012 and
obama had lost to mitt romney but
insisted he actually won and spent
months promoting on twitter and facebook
that he won and that mitt romney had
stolen the election and then on the day
when the electoral college votes were
being counted barack obama went to a
rally and told antifa and black lives
matter people let's go to the capitol
and then they did and they broke into
the capitol and a police officer died
do you think that the reactions would
have been the same from republicans what
do you think we would be seeing on fox
news what do you think we would be
seeing uh from the standpoint of of uh
the republican party on the floors of
the house and the senate give me a break
guys you need only imagine that scenario
to see the level of hypocrisy uh and
dishonesty and immorality that we are
seeing from republicans today very very
good post also an interesting question
from a user who goes by the name fred
osaurus on our subreddit who says will
trump divulge state secrets when he's
out of office i'm worried of the
national security risk that trump will
represent when out of office because
even if he can be removed from the
office he surely has state secrets in
his head that obviously can't be removed
i'm surprised he hasn't spilled already
but i'm wondering if any of you think he
will use his knowledge of state secrets
as a bargaining chip with his cronies or
who knows i wouldn't be surprised if the
russians approach him undercover or not
and try to get him to divulge some of
the things that would be useful to them
i i don't actually think so and there's
a couple things number one and this was
actually mentioned in the comments trump
hasn't been reading his uh presidential
daily briefings for a long time he
hasn't even been receiving the morally
for a long time so
trump knows way fewer state secrets than
most presidents because he's not been
paying attention for a very long time
and he doesn't really care number two
i don't actually think trump would would
do something like selling state secrets
for cash or anything like that i i don't
think that he would be morally against
it i just don't think that it would end
up being put together but i do think
it's quite plausible that in order to
brag
trump will say things to people he's not
supposed to be saying things to
um
often with trump
much of his behavior comes out of
incompetence or narcissism
rather than out of malice although
there's no shortage of malice for for
sure but let me know what you think
about that and join the discussion at
davidpakman.com reddit you know one of
the things i was thinking about
yesterday as we saw the second
impeachment of donald trump
is that for a guy who has been focused
on being a winner winning winning
winning and wanting to be the alpha and
wanting to be the big dog and wanting to
be respected in all of this stuff
there's really been no bigger loser than
donald trump from the standpoint of
american presidents and what he's done
to his party and what he's done to the
country donald trump as we mentioned
earlier has now been impeached twice
no president has ever been impeached
twice donald trump lost the popular vote
twice something no president has done
in more than 100 years it has happened
before but it's been more than a hundred
years donald trump's presidency oversaw
the loss of the house of representatives
for republicans in 2018 lost the house
trump's mishandling of the virus has
been not only historically disastrous
but it combined with his wackiness led
republicans to lose the senate in 2020
and it led to trump losing the
presidential race and making himself a
one-term president trump has been widely
banned from social media for completely
flouting the rules of those
social media platforms and in so doing
all of this donald trump has also
damaged his own businesses possibly
irreparably losing contracts with the
city of new york many of his businesses
decimated as we've discussed and will
lead to investigations of trump's
businesses for possible financial
wrongdoing
he has destroyed the reputations of his
children his son-in-law and so many of
the people around him possibly
irreparably and all of that talk that
trump always says you know no one's ever
seen anything like this like nobody's
ever seen before we've gotten used to
that phrase
he's right it's true trump is right
about that but unfortunately the
superlatives and unprecedented elements
of this presidency are all bad
and unfortunately
a lot of the awakening that we're seeing
didn't happen sooner
a lot of the damage was done by the time
this partial awakening happened but i
think it's also important for us to
understand that most trumpists have not
abandoned trump there's some good new
polling data that came out i believe it
was yesterday maybe this morning i saw
it this morning which shows that
although 10 republican members of the
house did vote to impeach donald trump
although
some senators are saying trump should go
pat toomey for example we've heard
critical comments from mitt romney
and some republican voters have
abandoned trump by and large trump
continues to be
supported by the republican electorate
and he continues to be
seen
as arguably the most dominant and
important force in the republican party
so the idea that on on wednesday at noon
trump becomes irrelevant to american
politics or to the republican party so
far it doesn't appear to be that way yes
members of the house and senate of the
republican party will as i have told you
start to distance they will go back to
saying we've got to focus on debt and
deficit and religious freedom and
lowering taxes and cutting regulations
and all of this stuff and they'll sort
of pretend trump never happened or
certainly that they weren't bigly
supportive of it
but for now the majority of the
republican electorate is sticking with
him and it's unclear whether there are
going to be consequences and
accountability for everything donald
trump has done
incredibly we know that trump still
thinks he did a great job he has
weaponized his narcissism and that's
exactly why he still thinks he did a
great job he thinks none of this stuff
is his fault
he believes he's the best when trump
says i'm the best president i've done
more than anybody else
he clearly believes it and it shouldn't
be ignored that despite all of the
losing trump has gotten things done
permanently and all of them are bad
the judges the court appointments the um
uh
that's irreversible they trump will
leave
they will stay continuing to damage the
country and much of that is thanks to
mitch mcconnell and many of the very
republicans that are now distancing they
put in trump's just uh judges and
justices and uh the time lost with
climate and the environment there's no
way to get that back that's irreversible
we can now try to do even more to make
up for it but every lost day we never
get back but trump's
greatest act or maybe better said his
strongest action to make america great
or greater
is only six days away which is going to
be donald trump leaving office
arguably as the biggest loser to ever be
the president of the united states we'll
have more on this on our instagram page
at david pakman show and you can also
find me on instagram at david.pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show has been and continues
to be
membership and membership is not just a
feel-good thing you get access to the
world-famous bonus show every single day
just for members as well as
free audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly at
joinpacman.com that's join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code vote
soon 18 all one word all lower case
become a member today
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to welcome back today peter
joseph who's the founder of the
zeitgeist movement and director and
writer of the film inter-reflections uh
of course based on his book uh peter
it's so great to have you back on
thank you david i appreciate you having
me hope you're doing well so i i'm
curious um
so much has happened over the last four
years and in particular over the last
couple of weeks really since the the
november election with
um
you know
literally dozens and dozens of events
that previously we would imagine to be
extraordinarily unlikely in the united
states i'm curious on a few different
levels number one based on your the
analysis and the perspective that you've
talked about on our program before that
you have about the way the united states
is organized are the events of the last
few weeks that that unlikely or is it
exactly the type of thing that your
perspective would would suggest is
inevitable in some sense
well the specifics are hard to pinpoint
but this kind of um right-wing
insurrection
coming from
what i feel is many many generations of
lower class oppression
isn't necessarily unpredictable
you know the
the there's this kind of a short-term
picture and a long-term picture as with
anything when it comes to to uh the
human condition in terms of causality
and human behavior
so on one side if you look at the events
of january 6th
you have this rather sparse insurrection
so to speak kind of a satire of a coup
if you will if you really kind of look
at it when they storm the capital and
then you relate that clearly to a
figurehead that has deep cult of
personality and has been propo promoting
things in a self-interest with no
responsibility and people have flocked
to him and they believed him and this is
where we end up so that's one
perspective i don't think you can just
blame for example donald trump
explicitly donald trump came from
somewhere he's a manifestation of
something i mean if look at his
character in and of himself he
represents really a kind of
kind of
extreme caricature of what capitalist
society is right it's really about
people i mean he's literally groomed
into this since his father's time and he
knows how to angle he's professional
angler and there's a there's a line
there with morality where someone goes
from being a good businessman to being
effectively a criminal and i think
there's debate as to how gray that area
is when you're dealing with exploitation
and gaming because that's what our
society is we're gaming that's what
people do this is the only theory that
really supports the kind of behavior
that our economy does is game theory as
people have modeled in the past in terms
of who will be successful and who will
not
so there's that so you have that kind of
character that comes from society but on
the other side you have people and again
it's sad because people become so upset
when they look at these images and they
see the
they see it effectively a kind of
domestic terrorist heir to this
right-wing insurgency and obsessed with
conspiracies they don't believe anything
it's easy to be upset with those people
but they have they came from somewhere
there's a reason why they have evolved
to where they've become and it's not
just donald trump as i said before i
think this society in america due to
socioeconomic inequality something that
we spoke about years ago in my book the
new human rights movement it's the core
focus of that book
socioeconomic inequality is one of the
largest drivers of destabilization than
anything it is it is the ultimate uh
precondition so to speak sociologically
that forces people into a kind of
antagonism even in a wealthy society
such as the united states the haves and
the have-nots have become so severe
throughout the years and if people don't
understand why they understand the
mechanics they understand the history
they start to feel they start to feel
like they're left behind so as bizarre
as it is that you have a white culture
in america that now feels they're
oppressed you know given the true
history of america where obviously the
white man particularly is far from the
most depressed but this is manifest from
this what i believe class inequality and
i think there's a great deal of
sociological research epidemiological
study that supports that so for me the
solution to all of this is create more
economic equality ultimately that's
really the most critical thing society
can do at this point to help it stop the
instability that i think is only going
to keep growing in many different levels
from the standpoint of um
we'll let i'll frame this up in a
slightly different way and get get your
thoughts on it um whenever we we've seen
over the last four years the next high
bar of crazy reached
sometimes there will be this feeling of
okay this is now over the line and
nobody is going to be okay with this and
then
we hear oh actually
it there's people who are okay with it
and then you see the social media posts
and then you see
the short memory uh uh that that many
have for for these sorts of things and
you see the way that the the media
apparatus sort of creates an environment
where no matter what takes place someone
is there yet that you can point to that
will actually say this is actually okay
or defend it in some way and we could if
we say what was the origin of this
we could come up with a lot of different
starting points but in terms of the
political media landscape i often think
back to the reagan welfare queen meme of
this imaginary woman who's having all
these kids and getting rich off of it
and has a cadillac and like once you
believe that then you go into
immigrants are dangerous and then you go
into trickle-down economics or whatever
right like fill in the blanks and then
you get to
hugo chavez and dominion and whatever
stole the election like the ultimate
caricature that we heard over the last
couple of months is that a fair way to
talk about the history and that that
makes it about a 35-year history or
would you kind of frame it up in a
different way well i i think that you're
you're touching upon how two things how
belief systems come to be and belief
systems share
shared uh uh excuse me a common
architecture so going back to reagan
thatcher and the rise of neoliberalism
where thatcher i believe her quote was
there is no society she's all about the
individual and this sort of
narcissistic um
righteous righteous self-individualism
came forward that
clearly has been deeply caustic and if
you believe things like well you get
what you work for or you just have to
pull yourself up by your bootstraps if
you believe that people have complete
free will and it's all up to them which
is that general gesture of all of this
then you're going to not care very much
about people that are actually suffering
legitimately because of the very
structure of the system do not have the
same advantages that other people do
because of the longer long generation of
inequality in many facets of that but
yeah i agree with you absolutely it's uh
it's
in the book i remember writing a whole
section on how the kind of right-wing
mindset can be created and how
particularly from that standpoint how
this if you like for example if you
believe that you get what you work for
then you probably also believe that
people that commit crime have absolutely
total responsibility right forget
they're there in poverty forget what
their life condition was so you end up
you know with that that kind of
distorted value system based on
narrow individualism and i think that
also is very much part of the society
because of the economic system once
again so my causality as you know david
is it's really all about what our
economy has done to us sociologically
and obviously psychologically and if you
have people that are stuck in a system
regardless of the reality of our
condition regardless of our potentials
for say post-scarcity um and they're
fighting with each other because of the
structure not because we have to but
because of the structure you're going to
have antagonism you're going to have
racism you're going to have all this
group versus group stuff you see it in
microcosms you see it macrocosms i was
on another podcast the other day and i
was reminded that in west virginia
i'm from the south and i had friends a
friend of a friend from west virginia
and they were describing to me something
surreal and how in west virginia before
nafta
the south and the north actually were at
odds because of economic strife if you
can believe that just like you saw you
see in italy in the north and south
historically as well which
also generated mob stuff but it wasn't
until nafta came along and jobs were
taken by people in the global south
that people started to hate people from
the global stuff they started to hate
mexicans so
you see that antagonism as well so
that's a good corollary
so one of the calls related to this that
i get frequently recently when i when i
hear from my audience is
how do we fix this and one of the
reactions i've had is if we grant that
it's taken 30 for to pick the reagan
thatcher example 35 40 years to get into
this
it would be unreasonable to expect that
in a two four or six year period of time
we would get out of it and some of the
things that have to be changed are on
the one hand as you're talking about
the sort of structure of the financial
system and inequality on the other hand
i when people ask me how can i convince
my aunt that she's wrong
i think that that's a that's what we
might call a retail strategy and we
could have that conversation but it's
less relevant to the fact that you
probably need a decade or longer of
cultural and
economic uh and educational change to
really start changing these things it
would other than by dictatorship
i don't know how you achieve the type of
change that has taken place over 40
years in a short period of time
i i certainly uh can sympathize with
that sentiment i would say on a certain
level the cultural shifts required
particularly when it comes to something
like racism which i do believe could
subside greatly in this country and
beyond it would take more than that
because racism has a snowball effect
racism started
as a
as a legal construct
where
in pre-excuse me in slavery period in
early america and many people don't
realize this
the indentured servants that were
imprisoned in in europe they were taken
over here they were used for about seven
years then they could be free that was
not the best business investment from
the standpoint of the plantation owners
and they started to learn about the
african transatlantic slave trade where
the kings in africa were kidnapping
their own people and literally selling
them to the dutch and other other slave
ships and they were brought over to
america as a new investment but the fact
that these people had black skin had no
relevance it wasn't until later in fact
they even intermarried with indentured
servants and had kids this is it wasn't
this taboo
it wasn't until the legal construct of
race was created to fortify racism in
and of itself
and create an excuse for it ultimately
and then after the civil war excuse me
after after the um after the after these
civil wars but before that the legal
construct was formal formalized even
more so so the poor black people
could be subservient to the poor white
people to avoid any kind of upheaval dr
martin luther king wrote about this uh
eloquently
how the birth of racism came to be and
it's not what people think it is so now
you have families that are racist
they've been racist for generations they
teach racist values to their kids how do
you stop that obviously that would take
generations but the economic foundation
is still there and i strongly believe
the stress of this strife and groupism
this group antagonism of our society is
to blame and if you can get rid of that
to whatever degree it's going to have an
equivalent positive effect on people's
bigotry so to answer your question i
would say to people obviously you need
policy shifts to create more equality i
am again i'm for demarcization i have
gone through the gamut in my mind
analysis i'm not a marxist and i don't
subscribe to anything socialist in any
kind of traditional sense i look at it
from a systems science perspective and
what we know uh in sociology and of
course efficiency when it comes to
systems we could go on the tangent of
why the system is unsustainable
ecologically and so on that's a big part
of it as well but in terms of this
sociology
excuse me
you have to start giving people what
they need directly so you should be in
favor of something like ubi as a
stepping stone people should
should literally want there to be
ultimately free food and free
transportation and a free foundation
there should be that we have the
resources to do that so first like
people need to understand that and they
need to understand that if we have our
needs supplied i'm not talking about
luxuries and excess we could still have
that as a top-tier market reality right
but you give people what they need the
no one's in poverty anymore
then you're going to see these shifts
happen and people need to understand
that that is not some kind of inhibition
of people's freedom and the propaganda
that we have or people just can't even
handle that concept we can't even talk
about universal health care in america
because some will inevitably attribute
it to socialism and then think we're
going to be in some gulag eventually
because we have universal health care
right so you see the point but i i can't
answer that question in any kind of
explicit way
i have plenty of proposals that i've
talked about it's obviously education
but you need to have policy shifts and i
will say this eventually
through a femoralization which is this
more with less phenomenon it is to me
the the only
real economic wealth that we have and
it's not wealth in the sense of a
physical good it's wealth in the sense
of an extremely efficient process uh
jeremy rifkin refers it to it as zero
marginal cost in reference to um to the
current society where we become so
efficient in a given area where we've
created technology that can can perform
actions at such great efficiency they
become cheaper and cheaper and cheaper
and smaller and smaller and smaller you
know the big computer you know 50 years
ago weighed many tons took enormous
amount of energy cost millions of
dollars now your cell phone ship is more
powerful that applied to just about
everything in society economically is
where i think localization and a return
to a kind of community-driven high-tech
reality where people get off the grid of
normal state control i don't mean state
in a derogatory way but there's the
limitations of using a telecom company
the limitations of having to buy your
food from a major corporation i believe
that people act accordingly and this is
the kind of stuff i get into at the end
of my my film into reflections which
begins what will be the second film and
i've commented on this in my book i
don't want to go into much detail but
it's about getting off the grid of the
market system as fast as we can through
localization and i'm working on a big
lecture in march describing a platform
where people can come in and start
engaging and feel what it's like to have
to have the community resilience and to
engage in networks that don't use money
let me talk a little bit so the this
concept of of zero marginal cost is
interesting
many people are familiar with the
economic concept of diminishing marginal
cost so if you imagine building a
factory to make one pair of shoes that's
a huge fixed cost investment and of
course as you scale up and you can make
more and more shoes more quickly the
additional cost per pair of shoes goes
down but it's still positive it's still
something it's just not as as much as as
previously right talk a little bit about
how zero marginal cost is possible and
in what areas it would be possible
i think you know we see it already when
it comes to digital transfer i mean
music while it costs money to create
even though substantially less than it
did before uh can be transferred across
the internet at zero cost you have the
comment excuse me of the cost of
electricity that's it films obviously
anything in the digital realm is the
easiest example you know it used to be
you'd have a big film projector then we
had a dvd now you can have free
distribution ultimately so that's the
easiest example but
zero marginal cost could apply to say
transportation systems if they were
efficiently created so you have
automated car systems you have even the
early subway systems that we have if
if done correctly it's still going to
cost something which means ultimately
there's going to be some kind of labor
some some kind of resource investment
but if it's done with the proper
efficiency there's no reason for the
public to have to submit to pay for it
and that can be applied to food systems
look at the efficiency of vertical farm
systems as as has been researched and as
i've also talked about in the past the
amount of resources is substantially
less the amount of water is
substantially less and you could easily
have vertical farm systems localizer
it's so efficient people don't need to
pay for it it doesn't mean that there
isn't labor so there's always going to
be some kind of labor but think about it
i use this example what if instead of
working 40 hours a week someone only had
to work five right would they do that if
they could get what they needed without
pay i think they would i think most
people if they were presented with that
they very much would um i so
with many of these systems it also
sounds like it's not necessarily about
nominal zero marginal costs but
eliminating waste makes it a net zero
like for the food system is a great
example where when you look at how much
is left in the fields because by the
time it gets to the grocery store it
would be bruised and then how much is
thrown out by the grocery store because
by the next morning it would be brutal
like by the waste elimination could make
it a net zero
yeah absolutely i mean it's all kind of
subjective depends on how you think
about labor and energy that goes into
something so obviously everything has a
quote cost if you put it in the
framework of labor and energy but
absolutely i completely agree uh the the
inefficiencies of our current system are
so so extreme because of what we've done
the average american food plate moves
about 2000 miles before it makes to your
plate which is
obviously that's not the way an economy
would function especially since there's
plenty of resources and land to localize
food production and when you do that the
efficiency increases the ultimate
element of efficiency has to do with
networking
just like on your cell phone you have
all of these things that used to require
tons and tons of apps there's a guy
named peter diamandis and he did a
calculation that the app potential on
your phone was worth millions of dollars
say a number of decades ago because you
don't need a separate audio player or a
separate film player so the networking
of things making things as unified as
possible is the ultimate post scarcity
um efficiency mechanism and that's what
we don't do in our society we have
corporations that are all divided
everyone's competing with each other you
have cell phone companies that are not
sharing an open source they're
constantly making new little
improvements they don't know what
they're going to do
the amount of waste created is is
staggering because there's no
collaborative environment it's a
post-facto collaboration ultimately
which doesn't help anything so
there's a lot to be said on that i my my
ultimately my focus these days
economically is on post scarcity and if
we can achieve and i i'll just comment
on this by the way i did see another
interview that you did a while back on
post scarcity and it was it was a good
interview but i noticed that there's a
when people speak about this they tend
to obsess about you know things like
automation and the the potentials but
really post scarcity is is a economic
world view in our current society
to have deficiency means to be able to
make money for people to be insecure
means they're more likely to go out and
buy something
efficiency sustainability and
conservation are the enemies of this
kind of system because the more problems
there are the more money can be made we
have a in china one of the richest men
in the world makes all of his money
multi-billionaire off of water bottling
so it's not good to have clean water if
if you know you want to make a bunch of
money right so you have to shift away
from that kind of
what effectively is artificial scarcity
creation that the market system just
does naturally this is what its natural
incentive is and people's mindset gets
shifted by that and suddenly people are
restricting things they don't even know
it you have value system disorders that
are created so and that's really where i
think the root of the ecological crisis
is i'll add one more thing to that on
this small tangent our entire society is
pushed by consumption so you know people
have to buy things they have to create
demand that demand inspires jobs people
have the jobs to get money to get
purchasing power and then the whole
cycle continues if you have a reduction
of people needing things for whatever
reason such as durability sustainability
confidence uh you're gonna harm the
economy as we know it and that's a very
that's a very caustic place to be as a
civilization yeah i mean i think in our
next conversation we should just focus
on environment and ecological issues but
what you're saying reminds me of within
the food system of something michael
pollan describes really well which is
that just our basic ingredients are very
hard to make very profitable because
they're just ingredients you can't do
much to them and that's where this idea
of well let's take the corn and we'll
make it inedible in its in its
ingredient form but we can grow a ton of
it in an acre and then we can extract it
and break it down to its component parts
and create food products which most
people don't even really know they want
but we'll create marketing in order to
tell people instead of just buying corn
on the cob here's something made with a
corn extract and that's what you should
go and and by i mean that's that's
essentially what you're describing
across multiple industries
yeah ultimately ultimately and then you
have just the psychological disorder
simultaneously when people's values
are
pushed into a social circumstance excuse
me people's values are being acclimated
into a social environment where people
get more and more and they want to keep
up with the joneses i mean i i was on
the last person to get a cell phone i
really didn't have the motivation to do
so but over time
everyone had one everyone's like oh why
can't i call you why can't i text you
and suddenly social inclusion kicks in
right and that is kind of a virus in our
society
so to speak where
this need for social inclusion that's
what advertising does it manipulates our
sense of sociality making us feel like
we are missing out on something and that
of course is another conversation in and
of itself yeah and then when you get
this stuff thanks to hedonic adaptation
you don't really feel any better about
now having had it because you're moving
to the next thing uh peter joseph
founder and z of the zeitgeist movement
director and writer of the film
interreflections it's always great to
talk to you and let's let's do it again
let's do it thank you david
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month plus you can get
the daily bonus show world famous at
this point and the daily commercial free
tv show by making those pledges at
patreon.com david pakman show this is
audience supported media we depend on
the support of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv or even
listen on the radio
dot com slash david pakman show
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
i've been uh sort of predicting warning
uh you guys everybody i've been talking
to that the next two years are going to
be particularly insane
for two reasons uh really three reasons
one
uh a large part of the country and even
many of our elected officials wrongly
believe that the president
uh joe biden will be illegitimate that
the election was really won by donald
trump but joe biden stole it that
radicalizes people number two
right-wing media is going to be crazier
than ever uh fox news now not radical
enough but fear not newsmax and oan and
some other online uh platforms and
outlets
are amping up the crazy and they will be
going absolutely no holds barred nuts
during the next two years and number
three
we actually have
q anon type conspiracy theorists who
have been elected to the house of
representatives we have absolutely nutty
republicans that if you this this is not
praise of like a mitt romney republican
but if you put a mitt romney republican
next to some of these people uh it's
hard to imagine how they're even um part
of the same party at all and i have a
perfect example for you that blends q
anon craziness with radical right-wing
media and it is a story about the new
brand new q anon congresswoman marjorie
taylor greene
who has announced an impeachment of joe
biden now you might be saying wait a
second joe biden's not even president
yet what impeaching joe biden what are
you talking about yes
and kooky congresswoman marjorie taylor
green announced it
on newsmax where else it's too crazy for
fox news so she went on newsmax and she
starts stammering because even she
doesn't fully seem to understand
why she's going to try to impeach joe
biden take a look well uh and yes 10 or
so republicans did this as well we'll
have more on that in a bit
congresswoman i understand though you
have something uh pressing something
important and something new you'd like
to share with everybody
yes i i would like to announce on behalf
of the american people we have to make
sure that our leaders are held
accountable we cannot have a president
of the united states that is willing to
abuse the power of the office of the
presidency
and be easily bought off by foreign
governments uh foreign chinese or
chinese energy companies ukrainian
energy companies so on january 21st i
will be filing articles of impeachment
on joe biden
wow
articles of impeachment on joe biden on
his first full day as president as funny
as her idiotic explanation is uh the
newsmax hosts greg kelly's reaction when
she's sort of like pretending this is
huge breaking news but in reality she's
she's just a a lunatic radical right
winger speaking nonsense
him having to pretend like this is wow
very very powerful is part of what makes
that clip just unbelievable now she may
well be telling the truth
that she's going to draft
impeachment articles against joseph r
biden jr on january 21 2021 just seven
days from today
what's nuts is we've been talking about
are republicans going to impeach joe
biden just for the hell of it and
apparently at least this one republican
is going to it will go nowhere because
democrats control the house
and democrats control the senate and
most importantly because joe biden
hasn't done anything worthy of
impeachment of course and if you needed
and the this is an early signal
that yes these people are going to be
just as crazy as they were during their
pre-elected official lives and yes
right-wing media is going to be levels
of crazy that we only previously
uh sort of skated by with fox news
take the craziest thing that's ever
happened on fox news
that's going to be 24 7 on newsmax and
that's going to be 24 7 on oan so
there's going to be no shortage of
insanity to debunk over the next two
years um and just a few other
we're going to talk about the metal
detectors at the house of
representatives on the bonus show today
so i don't want to say too much about it
but we now have uh a house of
representatives
increasingly riddled with
outrageous conspiracy theorists and
radicals marjorie taylor greene the
woman in the video we just played
a guy named madison cawthorne
they've admitted that they carry
firearms he admitted that he carries
firearms with him onto the house floor
multiple firearms he's in a wheelchair
and he says the wheelchair allows him to
actually have multiple firearms with him
marjorie taylor green uh saying she
legally has guns so why shouldn't she be
able to have them on the floor of the
house of representatives and now metal
detectors are going in to try to stop
that so these are really scary
outrageous people who are now in the
house of representatives and there's two
ways that this could go
um
the the optimistic path is that the
election of people like marjorie taylor
greene and madison cawthorne and others
is a blip
that remember members of the house are
up for re-election every two years
they're constantly the their campaigns
for re-election are going to start in
seven or eight months already
the hope would be
they did in their particular districts
very trumpy districts
ride the wave of trump-ism
to the house of representatives and that
they'll be gone in two years that's the
optimistic side
the more pessimistic side and the
scarier side is that although donald
trump will be gone we talked about how
his impact will continue through the
judges and supreme court justices that
he selected
this may also be the legacy of trump
people like these folks who may remain
in the house and there may be this wacky
q anon trumpian contingent that remains
in the house for some time it's very
scary and we almost immediately i mean
listen they'll start campaigning in
seven months we'll start dealing with it
in seven eight months as well but we're
going to have to activate to make sure
that these people are just one term
members of congress and we'll have
plenty of time to talk about that
one of the things i've discussed with
you guys um
a bunch over the last four years and
really over the last two months in
particular
uh are
a lot of these right wingers are a lost
cause and they voted for trump once or
twice whatever you know they may never
understand the error of their ways
but that it's important for us to
remember that there were lots of
supposed left wingers who back in 2016
maybe stayed home because they didn't
think it was important enough uh the
difference between trump and hillary and
they said ah i'm going to stay home if
it's these two i'm kind of opting out
some leftists said i almost would rather
it be trump if it's not going to be my
preferred candidate because hillary's
just a centrist shill and they would be
the same
and of course we found out that that's
very much not the case we have seen
donald trump do things that i never
imagined any president would do never
mind hillary clinton
um i have not been calling for apologies
but i have been saying it would be
important to recognize how wrong those
leftists were i did get a call from
someone this morning saying
i regret not voting for hillary in 2016.
it was wrong of me not to do that take a
listen
hey dave i'm holding my baby so if you
hear a little talk that might be him but
just want to call you and say with
watching the show on the 11th and i am
one of the people who did not vote for
hillary in 2016. right i voted for jill
and i regret that
since then i voted for joe this election
cycle because of people like you and
destiny who taught me about harm
reduction wow and i'm eternally grateful
for that so thank you for teaching me
about harm reduction buddy that was
really
really good for my life and really
probably good for the country
thanks anyway dave
so that's a beautiful voicemail and it's
great to hear things like that and we
also need to recognize that
in order to really get more change we
have to deprogram some of the 75 million
trumpists that sure you know we learned
something like what was it eight percent
of bernie supporters ended up voting for
trump instead of hillary in 2016. these
are relatively small numbers they could
have made a difference by the way
because it was so close in 2016. but
we really need to attack the issue of
the 75 million people who thought voting
for trump after four years of disaster
was was a good idea or at least a better
idea than voting for joe biden on
today's bonus show congresswoman liz
chaney facing major blowback after
embracing the impeachment of donald
trump in the house we will talk about
the metal detector guns on the house
floor fiasco that is plaguing the house
of representatives and ex-michigan
governor snyder
has been criminally charged rick snyder
criminally charged in the flint water
crisis we will talk about the charges
he's up against the possible penalty and
what we expect
flint still has a water problem
understand how long it's been flint
still has a water problem all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
you can get instant access to the bonus
show by signing up at joinpacman.com
it's quick it's easy you can use the
coupon code better21 to get yourself a
discount or
make a pledge
at patreon.com
david pakman show that will also give
you access to the bonus show in either
case i will see you then or otherwise
tomorrow reminder we are off monday for
the martin luther king day holiday off
monday but with you today for the bonus
show and tomorrow as well
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman